صورتها الصين على أنها عمل من أعمال
حسن النية لشحن لقاحات صينية الصنع
إلى دول أخرى حتى قبل
ضمان ما يكفي لمواطنيها ،
ذكرت وسائل الإعلام الحكومية أن 350 مليون
جرعة ذهبت
إلى أكثر من 80 دولة من بين
الدول على الطرف المتلقي
منغوليا المجاورة وفي الجنوب.
أمريكا تشيلي
حشد كلا البلدين بسرعة لوضع
تلك اللقاحات لاستخدامها
في منغوليا ، وقد تم تطعيم أكثر من 52 في المائة من
السكان بشكل كامل
تشيلي أقل بقليل من
معدلات التطعيم في العالم
إلى جانب دول مثل الولايات المتحدة
وإسرائيل ولكن لماذا  مع انخفاض الحالات
في تلك البلدان
، شهدت منغوليا وتشيلي
ارتفاعًا في عدد الإصابات الجديدة بـ covid19 الأسبوع الماضي
سجلت منغوليا مستوى قياسيًا في عدد الحالات اليومية
، وأعلنت السلطات في تشيلي
إغلاقًا شاملاً في جميع أنحاء عاصمتها
سانتياغو قبل أسبوعين في
بعض الأماكن التي يوجد فيها نسبيًا
تم تخفيف التغطية العالية للقاح وإجراءات التباعد الاجتماعي ،
فقد يكون الأمر كذلك
تم تخفيف هذه الإجراءات في وقت قريب جدًا ،
وهي واحدة من أكثر الاختلافات اللافتة للنظر في
أنواع اللقاحات
بينما تتحول الولايات المتحدة وإسرائيل إلى شركة فايزر
فيما وراء التكنولوجيا ،
وتعتمد منغوليا وتشيلي بشكل كبير
على اثنين من الصين
سينوفاك ومزرعة ساينو.
مقرها هنا في الصين ، تلقينا
جرعتين من مزرعة cyano في الأشهر الأخيرة
، تتراوح معدلات فعالية اللقاحات الصينية الصنع
التي تحتوي على فيروسات معطلة
من حوالي 50 في المائة
إلى 79 في حين أن شركة فايزر المدعومة من الولايات المتحدة
والمودرن التي تستخدم علوم mrna فعالة أكثر من 90 في
المائة على
الرغم من  تباينت البيئات التي
تم اختبارها فيها جميعًا باختلاف
أنواع
الفيروس المنتشرة ، ويبدو أن تلك المدعومة من الولايات المتحدة
أفضل بكثير في منع انتقال العدوى
مقارنة بلقاحات الصين في الوقت الحالي ،
ما يمكننا رؤيته بوضوح شديد
هو مستوى الأجسام المضادة لدى الأشخاص الذين
يتلقون البيونات.
أعلى بكثير من مستوى الجسم المضاد
لدى الأشخاص الذين يتلقون
الزليلي والذين سمحوا لكلا الجيوب الأنفية  ac and sino
farm للاستخدام في حالات الطوارئ
على الرغم من أن الشركات الصينية التي تقف
وراءها تقدم بيانات محدودة عن التجارب السريرية ،
لكن الخبراء الطبيين يحذرون من
أن اللقاحات الصينية أقل فعالية في
مكان ما مثل شيلي في مكان ما مثل
لقاحات منغوليا وقد أنقذت الكثير من
الأرواح
ولكن ربما  لم يتمكنوا من إيقاف
انتشار الفيروس
والتسبب في التهابات خفيفة لدى
الأشخاص الذين تم تطعيمهم
، ومن ثم بالطبع احتمال
حدوث عدوى أكثر خطورة لدى الأشخاص الذين
لم يتم تطعيمهم بعد
، وهذا أحد القيود المفروضة على
اللقاح الأقل فاعلية
بشكل عام  الحالات في منغوليا
وتشيلي آخذة في
الارتفاع ، فقد تساعد اللقاحات في تقليل
شدة تلك الحالات
إذا نظرت في جميع المجالات في
البلدان التي لديها معدلات تطعيم أعلى
معدلات
الاستشفاء تلك معدلات الوفيات هذه
بينما قد تتحرك قليلاً
كما هي  ربما يكون أفضل بكثير الآن مما
كان يمكن أن يكون بدون
اللقاحات لأن اللقاحات أكثر ر  قم
بأي شيء آخر بغض النظر عن أيهما
يساعد في الحماية من الأمراض الشديدة
والوفاة لمنع انتشار الفيروس بشكل أفضل ،
دول مثل البحرين والإمارات العربية المتحدة التي
اعتمدت أيضًا بشكل كبير على مزرعة سينو في الصين
تقدم الآن لمواطنيها جرعة ثالثة
كمعزز
الاختيار هو لقطة ثالثة للمزرعة الصينية
أو يمكنهم استخدام لقاح pfizer لأن
تطوير
اللقاحات وتوزيعها أصبح مسيسًا للغاية
خاصة بين الولايات المتحدة والصين
وإذا رفض كلا البلدين التعرف
على لقاحات بعضهما البعض
التي يمكن أن تجعلك محدودًا  لعبور
الحدود بناءً على اللقاح الذي
حصلت عليه
لمنع
السفر الدولي من العودة إلى ما يقرب من الطبيعي
لسنوات قادمة إلى هنا في الصين ، فقد
أبلغوا مؤخرًا عن إعطائهم مليار
جرعة للأشخاص الذين يعيشون
هنا وقد رفعوا مؤخرًا
هدف التطعيم الخاص بهم  على أمل تطعيم
ما يصل إلى 85 في المائة من أكثر من
1.4 مليار شخص يعيشون هنا في وقت لاحق من
هذا العام  الأذن
ولكن لا يزال من غير المعروف ما إذا كان بإمكانهم الوصول إلى
مناعة القطيع خاصةً بالنظر إلى
فعالية اللقاحات الصينية
ضد متغير دلتا الأكثر سهولة في الانتقال
والذي لم يُعرف بعد ، ولذلك هناك
تقارير تشير إلى أن الإجراءات الحدودية الصارمة
ستظل
سارية حتى عام 2022.
يضيف مسؤولو الصحة الصينيون جرعة ثالثة هنا جنبًا إلى جنب مع
اقتراح
لخلط اللقاحات الصينية والأمريكية
مع التركيز على جعلها
أكثر فعالية.